- My name is Meena Vembusubramanian,
and I lead product management
for AWS Transform for Mainframe.
We are here today to talk about de-risking
your mainframe exit through refactoring
by leveraging agentic AI.
Joining me this afternoon,
you'll hear directly from Frank Uslaub,
who is the vice president of
transformation programs at BMW
and Vimal Brahmbhatt, who's
the senior vice president
of technology at Fiserv.
We'll start the day
today with some context
that if you found your
way here this afternoon
might be a little bit familiar to you
on the challenges associated
with mainframe modernization.
We'll talk about AWS Transform's
agentic AI capabilities
with that context in mind.
Next, we'll get to the
really interesting stuff
and hear directly from Frank
and Vimal on their organizations'
transformation journeys.
We'll end our conversation today
with the key success patterns
that we're seeing from
both customers here today,
as well as across the board
on the refactor pattern and beyond.
Standing here towards
the end of 2025 today,
there are still over 220 billion lines
of COBOL in production,
and these lines of COBOL actually power
70% of critical enterprise applications.
We're hearing from customers
constantly that their teams
that operate these
applications are restricted
from their ability to be agile
and really adapt these applications
to the changing business requirements
as quickly as they would like to do.
And when they do address
the transformation process,
what they find is that they're encumbered
by multi-year efforts
and a lot of risk in terms of
validating these applications
and getting them across the line.
These teams well understand the benefits
associated with modernization.
They know that they'll
see better costs often,
particularly as their applications scale.
They'll have access to modern
as well as open source
technologies to innovate quickly.
They also know that the
talent conversation becomes
a little bit easier and
they have more flexibility
as they start looking at a variety
of different stacks moving forward.
And with this combined,
they're able to keep up
with the business changes
and innovate quickly with
their technology stack.
However, despite all of these
benefits teams often find
that the balance is
outweighed by the risks
associated with the modernization process.
Modernization requires
investing in not just
the transformation process and validation,
but in parallel, continuing to invest
in the day-to-day operations
of running your existing workloads.
Teams know that there is a lot
of risk given the criticality
of the business applications
we're talking about here.
In doing that validation
and switching over to that
modernized application.
And this process requires
a unique skillset,
you're looking for individuals
that understand the legacy application,
understand what the
architecture should look like
in the modernized world,
as well as people at that
intersection who understand both
and can really drive
that migration process.
My background personally before AWS
is in robotics and automation
in the context of factories
and Amazon's fulfillment centers.
The thing I loved in that
context was that ability
to leverage robots for what they do best,
high precision tasks, lifting heavy loads
and highly repetitive tasks.
While combining humans into that process
to do what human beings do
best, the high judgment tasks
and the tasks that require fine dexterity
and judgment at every step along the way.
So in the factory context,
you might have a robot
that is able to maneuver a heavy car door,
but you bring the human being in
in order to install a minute wiring panel
so that your end product
is at a high quality
and the process end to end is efficient.
The thing that's been resonating
with me in the past year
is this ability with agentic AI
to combine different approaches
fluidly in one workflow.
So what we're able to do now,
which is starting to change
the game, is leverage agents
that have deterministic processes
for specific tasks like
extracting dependencies
from source code or doing
like for like transformation
of code from COBOL to Java
in order to achieve
functional equivalents.
We can combine those with LLM-based agents
for understanding the source code
and producing natural
language documentation
for teams to move forward with.
All of this can happen
fluidly in one workflow,
bringing in humans in the loop
to make the high judgment decisions.
Things like figuring out
how to draw the lines
between different business domains
to decompose your monolith
into distinct applications
that you wanna move forward with
in your modernization journey.
With this, we're starting to see
the balance shift over the past year.
Connecting the ability to
understand legacy systems
to understand the business
logic associated with them,
communicate that in natural language
to both your business users as
well as your technical users
now really reduces the time
that teams have had to spend
in this understand phase of figuring out
what that application does to begin with.
This also really helps the experts
that are working on this get a lot further
and be a lot more effective
in the amount of code
and the number of
applications they're able
to process in the same amount of time.
Enabling agents to
interact with each other
and constantly learn and improve
and iterate on the process
through a understand, transform, test loop
that then again iterates on the process,
is helping us get a lot more efficient
and reduce the risk associated
with the output and the
risk that's handed over
to that final validation team
before you approach the cut-over process.
In combination, this AI first
approach has really helped us
transform modernization into
something that is trackable
for many more teams across organizations.
I wanna tell you a little bit today about
what we've been investing
in with AWS Transform.
AWS Transform for mainframe,
our hypothesis here is to
bring this hybrid approach
that leverages the right technology
for every step along the way.
With that in mind, we're gonna automate
the entire transformation process
from initial analysis and
planning through that refactoring
and that heavily intensive testing
and validation phase as well.
Our goal here really is to
bring those multi-year efforts
down to the order of months,
and that's what you'll hear
from Vimal and Frank about today
in terms of how that's
translating in their organizations
and in addition to this
like for like functionally
equivalent refactoring
that we'll hear from these teams on,
we're bringing LLMs into the
picture to improve the quality
of that refactored code
that forward looking teams
are going to be managing.
We do this by leveraging
a multi-agent process
to what we're calling
reforged refactored code,
to make it more readable
and more easy to maintain for your teams
that will be operating these
modernized applications.
Let me tell you a little bit about
what the AWS Transform journey looks like.
At a high level, there's three phases.
At the first phase, you're really looking
to understand the legacy application.
This begins with code analysis
to get a static view of the system.
Next, we recently introduced
an activity analysis agent,
which looks at the SMF
records in an organization
to get a dynamic view of the system
to understand things like the frequency
at which applications are
run, what the CPU utilization
for applications looks like, and so on.
Our goal here with this activity
analysis is to give teams
the information they need
to prioritize workloads
as well as to make architecture decisions.
For example, if you have a
medium frequency application
that's very short-lived process,
that's very short-lived, that
might be an ideal candidate
for an event driven
architecture moving forward.
The final part of analysis
involves data analysis
where we look at, for every data source
in your legacy system,
we look at what the
interdependencies look like
and we look at what
different programs might act
on the same data sources.
In addition, we provide a data dictionary
that helps you at a field level understand
what each data type is
and what the function
of each data source and fields looks like.
Next, we take all of this
and leverage our AI-based
agents to extract business logic
as well as technical documentation
based on the user persona
that's working on the
project on your team.
All of this information together goes into
an automated decomposition process
that your teams can bring
their own business context
and input into to help
decompose into distinct domains
and create a migration plan.
Following this understand phase,
we get into the transformation journey.
AWS Transform supports multiple
patterns for transformation.
Some teams might have time constraints
or particular data center exit timelines
and are looking to move very quickly.
They might choose to
re-platform workloads.
Next, what we're gonna hear about today
and spend more time on is
the refactoring process
where teams are working
on highly business critical workloads
and have a very keen need
for functional equivalence of
that modernized application
as compared to the legacy system.
This refactor process is
augmented by a reforge capability
that I'll talk about in more detail.
Finally, we also support
reimagining applications
where your starting point is
that business rules extraction,
which can go into a spectrum
forward engineering process,
leveraging smart IDs like Hero.
The last leg of the journey is
often the leg of the journey
that teams see the most
risk and most effort
and cost go into, which is in
that testing and validation
before you're finally able
to deploy into your cloud
or final destination.
Here for testing, we've
introduced a few capabilities
this year that we're
gonna continue to add to.
The first thing we've introduced
is automatic test plan generation,
which early in the process
lets you get an understanding
for every given application
what that testing scope
and what the effort
associated with it might be.
I wanna talk about a
couple of the capabilities
that Vimal and Frank's teams
have been using extensively
to provide the context
before you see the results
from these organizations.
The first piece of it is
this reforge functionality.
After code is refactored,
we run it through
a multi-agent process called reforge.
Much like melting metal and
reforging it makes it stronger
and improves its properties,
our goal here is to analyze
that refactored code
to identify any COBOL
semantics and structure
that have been carried forward.
We then improve on this
code using LLM-based agents
to restructure it into more
native feeling Java classes,
improve on things like variable names
that might in the past
have COBOL semantics
to reflect more business context terms
for these variable names.
The end result is code that
looks much more intuitive
and much more familiar
to a Java developer.
They're able to read the
code and make connections
to what the business logic being executed
by that code actually looks like.
The other thing we added
recently is functional testing
within this loop of reforging code.
So our goal there is to ensure
that when you have reforged code,
we're not introducing any
additional functionality changes
that might encumber your path
to getting to that functional
equivalence proof point
and finally getting your
application in production.
The next piece of what we introduced is
around accelerating
functional testing itself.
We talked about that test
plan generation upfront,
which helps teams very early
in the process understand
what the costs associated
with testing might be
and helps them also make
prioritization decisions
based on how many test cases
and how detailed these
test cases associated
with specific applications
might look like.
The other two pieces we
introduced today are scripts
that help accelerate specific
steps in the process.
The first one addresses something
that we know takes teams a lot of time,
which is gathering the test
data from the mainframe.
When you have a test plan that
was automatically generated,
we also help you create
test data capture scripts
that correspond to this test plan.
So what that looks like is JCL scripts
that you can run on your mainframe
to capture the very specific
form of test data that you need
to correspond to the test
cases you've identified.
Finally, we also provide
fully automated test scripts
to execute these tests on the mainframe
and on your modernized environment.
Today so far we've talked
about the discovery process
and the acceleration we're bringing there
to extract the broadest set of insights
in the deepest manner possible.
Next, we talked about reforge,
which is our capability
to combine the deterministic
refactor process
with LLM-based agents in order
to produce more readable,
highly maintainable Java code.
Finally, we also talked about
our test acceleration
capabilities that we've seen
real results from our customers thus far,
and it's something we'll
continue to invest in.
Now let's hear about
some real world examples
on how these features are
being used in the context
of real organizations.
I'm gonna call up Vimal to come
tell us the story at Fiserv.
- Thank you Meena.
Good afternoon everyone.
Thanks for joining us.
Before I start, let me ask a quick poll.
Raise your hand if you
have finished 10,000 steps
to make it to this conference.
Awesome. Love it.
If you can navigate these
re:Invent sessions, I guess we can get
through the modernization
of mainframe. (chuckles)
Quick introduction, Vimal
Brahmbhatt, I work for Fiserv.
How many of my colleagues here
who are from financial institutions?
If you don't mind. Awesome, awesome.
So this will be more relatable to you all.
I'm joined by my colleague Amir Mahmoud,
then AWS and HCL here in this room.
Amir is running this
modernization for all of us.
So let's get into the detail right away.
Let me talk about Fiserv,
what we are, who we are.
I'm sure some of you have
heard about this company.
Maybe some of you may not know.
So let's talk about who we are.
So Fiserv is a financial
payments processing organization.
Unbeknownst to some of you
we process pretty much,
in the US, third of the
economy in United States.
We are also a global company.
We have APEC AMEA presence
where we help out our customers.
Let me draw your attention
to some of these numbers.
We support 6 million plus merchants
and when I talk about
merchants, think about them
as like starting from
Amazons all the way up
to the mom and pop shop at the corner
and anything in between.
We support about 1.6 billion issued cards.
This is through our
partnership with the banks.
We also have 10,000 banking institutions
who uses our software to
run their banking course.
And at our peak we process close to
about 25,000 transaction per second.
And I want you all to pause for a moment
and think about the scale
I just talked about.
At this scale, transforming
mainframe into AWS
or any cloud processing
is not a small feat.
It's complicated and I'm
sure all of you are here
because somewhere you have
mainframe in your world
and you understand the complexity.
I have coded on some of
these platforms myself
many years back, so I have utmost respect
and understanding for this.
But those of you who do not know about
what I'm talking about from
the number perspective,
let's talk about the what it
means in our day-to-day life.
So here I have, these are
just illustrative examples.
Of course, we all have
been here at AWS re:Invent
for 3, 4 days so this does not
depict our re:Invent journey,
but whenever you go
back, this kind of shows
our journey of everyday life.
You get up, you are on your phone,
you need to buy something,
you make a purchase at online retailer
and then you're ready to go to office.
We are five days in office,
so I have to go to office every day.
You get your coffee on the
way, you get your car charged
or you get your gas, you make a payment
through either your mobile
phone, tap your card,
insert your card, whatever
it is, and then after that,
you are in the office.
So that subscription pops up
that I have to pay for my subscription.
You pay in a purchase,
then the lunchtime comes.
You order your food, gets delivered.
Of course your kids
wanted the new PS5 or 6.
You order that.
Before you go home, spouse calls you that,
"Hey, get some groceries
from the grocery store."
So you order ahead or you
go to the grocery store
and get your grocery.
You reach home, now you're
so tired you decided
that I want to treat
family with a good dinner.
So you take them out,
you go to the restaurant,
there's the clover device,
the white box which is shown there.
We also have point of
sale solution which we...
A lot of businesses, if
you are at a coffee shop,
one of the famous coffee shop which was
on the previous slide,
they use this device.
So you would know what I'm talking about.
In general, I'm just
explaining what we all do
every single day in our
life and that happens
about 350 to 400 million
times every single day.
350 to 400 and during the peak season
we just are in the peak season as we call
in financial industry.
We have Black Friday. We
have day before Thanksgiving.
We have Cyber Monday.
These are the days where we considered it
as a peak season for all of us.
So I hope this kind of gets the idea about
what I'm talking about
payments processing.
With that as a context, let's talk about
how we got here in our
journey with Amazon.
So as a company we
decided to kind of pivot,
and we said that well
we want to be on cloud.
And we partnered with Amazon
AWS a couple of years back.
We started thinking about,
how do we net new build outs?
We will do all on cloud.
There are certain application
we'll start migrating
onto the cloud, and there are some
which are kind of lift and shift as well.
So we have done all of
this, flavors of this.
So think about this,
we have a lot of applications
running in AWS as we speak.
A lot of them are net new,
a lot of them are migration.
And this last couple of years journey
has given us an opportunity
to now think about doing this at scale,
which is, as I explained,
unparalleled to anything.
I used to work for another
bank before I joined here
and some of these big institutions
have huge mainframe presence
and a lot of big workload
processes on mainframe.
And the kind of people does the innovation
around the mainframe,
but not on the mainframe.
So what you will do, you
will take your DB2 data,
resend it, replicate it somewhere
and build the services off of that.
But nobody really touches the mainframe
because it's hard, it's complicated there.
A lot of institutional knowledge is there.
We don't have people who understand this.
So that's the journey.
So now let's talk about
what particular application
we are transforming here
called HDC, host data capture.
I explained how payment works,
but let me draw your
attention to whenever you use
your credit card debit card, in-app tap,
these are like a four pillars
of how transaction flows through.
So all of us who are customers
here in the first box,
you initiate your payments
either for purchasing online
or card present, which is the in store.
Then of course, wherever you are,
whichever entity you are
buying your stuff from,
that's called merchant.
Then acquirer is where
we are focused today.
Fiserv plays actually in
acquiring network and issuing,
but we are focused on
acquirer code switching
and pre-settlement processing.
Then comes the Visa, MasterCard, Amex,
Discover, StarX, (indistinct).
These are all the credit debit networks
and at the end, the card
you have in your pocket,
if it's a JP Morgan Chase issued card,
Bank of America issued card,
Goldman Apple issued card,
that's where the final decision happens.
So in this entity we are
focused on the middle box
where it says pre-settlement processing.
So think about this, when
you buy something online
and you go to your bank,
it shows that you have
a pending transaction.
You would've noticed
that on your mobile app
or your statement which
says pending transaction.
And the next time when you look
at it that pending goes away
and it shows up on your statement
that this is the card.
We are talking about that journey only...
We are not even,
just a small journey between pending
and how it gets cleared.
So that's the focus here we have today.
So let's look at the application
itself, what it does.
The application name,
we are host data capture
as name might suggest that this is
a pre-settlement processing application.
It powers the ingestion
and the pre-settlement
processing for high volume data.
This application runs 24 by seven.
So let me also give you a perspective.
When you buy something online
before your order ships,
a merchant needs to get paid
before they will ship your order.
So when you make the purchase,
there is an offline
processing which happens
where your order came in and now we have
the merchant is asking for money.
So we have to match and
flag your original purchase
with the merchant asking
for money, flag them
and make sure that it is all reconciled.
So that's what the reconciliation
mean here, 24 by seven.
Just to give you an idea,
the numbers you see on
the right hand side,
this application is
responsible for processing
close to 10 billion plus dollar
payment processing every single day.
B with capital letter B, $10 billion.
Between 150 to 200 million
transaction every day,
goes without saying it's 24 by seven.
So this is the scale of the application
we are talking about,
where we have embarked the
journey of modernization.
Given those stakes, we
also have to appreciate
and understand where it's running today.
So it is running on
mainframe, 20, 30 years
of hardened mainframe,
millions of lines of COBOL code
and I'm sure some of you
are actually developing
on mainframe today.
So you appreciate and understand.
Guess what these applications
have done for us.
Non-functional requirements,
response time is utmost critical for us
because those merchants
want to get paid on time.
There is no delay we can tolerate there.
The capacity and the
availability of these platforms.
This platform has served us really well.
So before we really migrate away from this
and go on to the cloud
journey, our standards,
the table stakes are we need to make sure
that at a minimum this
functionality remains as it is
and we do not break anything.
The reason for....
So there's an interesting,
I've been in an industry
where there are a lot
of mainframe application and
there are a lot of new builds
and the culture friction between
those who are building new
versus those who are on this
mainframe type application.
It's very stark difference, right?
Because everyone is a
developer, everyone thinks
that I'm the best and I
know what I'm talking about.
Where we are missing out,
in a leadership position,
I personally feel like if
we do not really innovate
and if we do not transform,
we are going to miss out
on this whole agentic AI,
what AI has to promise.
And this is the critical aspect
of why we are embarking on this journey.
Quality has to remain as well.
So the conventional path helps,
but at this scale it really
creates the bottlenecks.
So what we did was, as
Meena actually describes,
I won't go in a lot of details,
but we started working with AWS about
seven or eight months back
where AWS has this product.
Now it's called refactor.
We called it Blu Age to
convert your COBOL code
into Java code and one of my goals is
to make sure that I have those
who are on a a COBOL
mainframe application,
I want to make sure
that I keep them around.
I keep them interested
in what we are doing.
I also want their expertise
because a lot of that
knowledge is in their head.
So what we did was we said,
"Okay, we are going to
convert COBOL into Java,"
which kind of looks and feels like COBOL
for divisions identification,
procedure, data, whatnot.
So when you read Java code they
understand what it's doing.
Soon we realized that once we do that,
we would have to spend
another 12 plus months
to really make it modern application.
The API-based application
event driven architecture
framework-based Java code,
this is where Meena and team
actually came to us and said that,
"Well, we have this product
before it becomes GA,
we would like you to see
if you are interested
in trying this, which is called refactor.
Which is the one of the agentic AI process
where it takes the refactored Java code
and then it builds the
modern Java application
by using this AI.
And because we were
embarking on this journey,
we decided that, we believe that,
I think this is the right step.
We decided to use reforge
to really change it from
COBOL looking like Java to real Java.
So we combined those two steps
and this is where again I think Meena
covered a lot of these things.
Our original journey would've
been about 30 months.
So we took this back, we
said, "Okay, well let's decide
how we want to do this."
Amir and team actually got together.
We said we will take a
piece of application.
Of course there are multiple modules,
many, many lines of code.
So we took one piece of application.
We took that refactored code,
ran it through the reforge.
We basically made sure that
current team also understands
and automation, the testing
piece, the automation piece,
continue to make sure that
we can test the functionality
and not drift from the functionality.
So all the results look so promising
so far we are in about two or three months
of the journey here,
but we feel confident that
this 30 plus month journey
we might be able to finish
it in about 18 months.
And we are three or four months into this.
So we are quarter of way there,
some ways to go but we
are very, very excited
about this journey.
So before I show you, and I think...
Did you show the code? No,
you didn't show the code.
So before I show you the code,
how it looks like it's maybe on our chart,
let's talk about a little
bit of a tech portion of it.
All of you know that we
have COBOL, VSAM, DB2,
Flatfile, (indistinct) database.
We are converting that
into Springboard CICS.
If your online application
goes into the Apache Tomcat,
JCL gets into Groovy.
Again, I think our principle was
business logic must be preserved,
functional equivalence guaranteed.
So that is like table stakes.
We cannot change what it does.
We cannot change from 10 billion
to 8 billion processing every night.
We have to keep up 10 billion
and make sure that we can
process 20 billion tomorrow
after this application is migrated.
And of course leverage AWS's services
once we are on the
other side of the fence.
Hope to remove the legacy
tech dependencies there.
Another thing, so we have
some operational users
who uses the output of these applications
to do the charge back to
reconcile some of the data.
So they have screens and they have
standard operating procedures.
We don't want to change that.
We don't want to retrain
the entire organization
just because we are modernizing our app.
So that's another aspect
that we are keeping up
with this transformation.
So let's look at the code quickly.
I know our chart may not be as visible,
but what I'll say is on the left hand side
is what you see, the refactored code.
This is using the Blu Age.
This is where we started.
And if I show you the whole code,
it basically feels like
COBOL returned in Java.
It was good when when
we started the journey,
we did not have reforge at that time.
So reforge is there now.
Now the right hand side of
the code is the reforged code
and the beauty of the reforged code is
that if you're a Java developer
who has never coded in COBOL
and start writing the code here,
they would kind of
understand the right side
of the code much better
because I think it does a tremendous job
of building the modern Java
with the variable names are meaningful,
unless on the left side
you really need to know
what you're looking at.
So idioms are there, the data
classes are there as well.
So this is what it looks like
and I think we really want to go
to the reforge code because here's one
of the other challenge we
have is talent challenge.
I'm not getting any college
grad, coming out of college
to come and code on a
mainframe application.
I hope that's the same challenge
all of you're facing as well.
So we have to spend time on
training them, less interest,
but if I get a college grad
to come and work on the code
which is on the right hand side,
they all are familiar with it.
This is what schools
are teaching them today.
So I think there are a lot of benefits
of refactoring this whole code.
With that, so I'll
conclude the presentation.
Our expectations when we are done
with this whole transformation, as I said,
our expectation is that
we want to continue
to do 10 billion while our
goal is to do 20 billion
because now I can put in multi regions,
I can now spin up all the
lambdas whenever I need.
I don't have to rely on MIPS utilization.
So continue to make sure that
there are zero disruption,
tech stack, tech stack
will be modern tech stack.
Now we can leverage all the
services, all the tooling.
We can also be innovative in using the AI
as well in payments
processing, which by the way
payment processing, there are
some use cases for AI in fraud
and risk, not in actual
payment transaction processing.
We are, I think we are looking at
some of those as well here.
Modern developer
experience, you can use IDE
for example versus you
have to code on VX code
on the mainframe.
So a lot of good uplift as
part of the transformation.
Of course number of months
we will be looking to,
because we are using reforge
and again I think I cannot
thank enough to Meena
and team about introducing
this reforge to us
that cuts down our journey by
almost like 12 plus months.
And when it's all said
and done had we stayed
with the refactored code
versus going to Reforge,
Reforge is going to uplift
our maintainability by 40%,
which is another huge thing, right?
So we had choice of either
staying with refactor
or go to Reforge code, 40%
is a huge humongous uplift.
So that's where we are, I'm
sure no transformation is easy.
I've done a lot of this in my career,
of course not at this scale.
I've worked on this platforms
but this is the first time we are
embarking this journey.
So I don't expect this to be flawless.
There will be bumps,
there'll be challenges,
we will have a lot of lessons learned.
We'll continue to share that
with our partners as well.
So in short, I think we had a car,
we changed everything around that car.
Now we are changing the
engine while car is running
and making sure that
nobody spills their coffee
at the checkout while car is running.
Speaking of car, I have
Frank here who is going
to talk about journey for a
car manufacturing company BMW.
So I'll hand it over to
Frank. Thanks everyone.
(audience applauds)
- Yeah, thanks a lot.
Quite impressive number
we've seen from Fiserv.
So now let's jump from
finance to automotive.
So first of all I would
like to introduce myself.
So I'm Frank Uslaub, leading
our BMW group IT's cloud
and modernization journey.
So before I jump to our
challenges on the mainframe,
I would like to give you some insights
into what makes us focus on these topics.
And I would like to start
with some insights from
a product perspective.
So I think most of you know
BMW and our fantastic products,
but now with our NEUE KLASSE
we are not just taking
a step ahead, we are
entering a new dimension.
The new design is clean,
modern and instantly BMW.
The fully electric performance
enables up to 400 miles range
and inside the panoramic iDrive
and the completely new
electronic architecture
creates a smart and more
intuitive digital experience
and with around 30% less lifecycle CO2
and a higher share of secondary materials,
the NEUE KLASSE also sets new benchmarks
on sustainability and circularity.
As a first model of ENEUE
KLASSE, the BMW iX3,
it showcases the innovations
that will shape the entire BMW
lineup, marking the beginning
of a new era that will
expand to 40 models by 2027.
So if you look at that
change on the product side,
it's quite clear that
that also means a massive
change on the IT side.
That new era on the
product side is enabled
by further digitalization of
our end-to-end value chain.
So we integrate AI into our core processes
on the engineering side,
on the production side,
on the sales side and
on financial services.
That's based on a cloud first strategy
where we have built new
applications in the cloud
and modernized and migrated
our existing applications
to move them into the cloud.
We started transformation
program in order to do it
and we tried to be as fast
as efficient as possible.
And in order to do that, we
copied a lot of approaches
which we have from our factories
and started actually a
transformation factory.
And our clear ambition
is to use automation
and especially AI as an accelerator.
So we have been pretty successful so far.
So the majority of our
applications is running already
in the cloud and we also
modernized our SAP landscape
and put it into the cloud
and we have more than 600
productive AI use cases
running on a daily basis.
But in addition to our
modern IT landscape,
we also have some legacy applications.
So typically in areas where
there was no process change
in the last couple of years,
so there was no need to update
or to migrate these applications.
So we just keep them stable.
But now basically, if you want to optimize
your end-to-end processes
and you want to embed AI at some stage,
you also touch these legacy systems
and that's where the challenge comes up,
and it's really difficult
to keep the process
and IT knowledge
for these legacy applications
if things have not been
changed in the last couple of years.
So that's why we made the clear decision
to modernize our application landscape
and to migrate away from our mainframe.
What is quite important for us is that
with a topic we also want to
master one of the challenges
we see on the talent side.
Yeah, so it's not so easy for us,
it's quite easy actually
to get COBOL engineers,
but it's not so easy really to get people
who also have proposed this knowledge
combined with the technology.
So that's one of the
big motivations for us
to drive the change.
When we started looking
at how are we going
to do the migration, we first
analyzed our applications
and found out they are quite complex
and we have a lot of dependencies
and also documentation was not up to date,
and we did not have proper test cases.
So we came to the conclusion
that we will only be able
to master that modernization
and to master the migration
if we can do it really
in the smarter way with benefiting
from capabilities of AI.
So how does it look like?
We have explored a couple of ideas
and at the end we defined
our modernization approach.
In general, we try not to combine changes,
technical changes with functional changes
since that increases complexity
and also slows you down.
But there are a couple of areas
where it's just the need to do so.
In that cases we used AWS
Transform together with Kiro
taking over the existing
business logic as a basis
and then adjusting it to be future ready.
In the other areas we focused
on the technical change,
with refactoring, of course
we did some code improvements
and also performance optimization,
but we kept the opportunity to compare
the actual test result of
the refactored application
with our original application.
Because we've seen a huge advantage
in safeguarding the refactoring approach
based on that technology.
In general, getting testing
on a new level was needed
to really speed up.
So doing like a code
conversion in a very short time
and then ending up with needing months
for proper testing is
nothing which looked for us
to be a right way forward.
And it was not an option.
So we really focused on
speeding up with the test,
with all the testing activities
from test plan generation
to test integration.
So how does that look like in detail?
Let's look at one of our applications
and it's actually a pretty small one.
In the past only the
process and the IT experts
have been able to tell
us what's really going on
in the application and
what kind of variance
do we need to test.
So for that application, it
took the teams about 10 days
to prepare 137 test cases
and in addition about two days
to prepare the corresponding test data.
And the experts even
missed some of the variance
which later caused issues in production.
With AWS Transform, the business
logic could be extracted
from the actual source
code and the test cases
have been created in
just a couple of hours,
including validation and also the creation
of the test data could be
done in an automated way.
That helps us to speed up the migration
and also to safeguard the go live
of our migrated applications.
Looking at our landing zones.
So for us it was quite
important to get really rid
of all of the dependencies
we had previously
on the mainframe, so that was
already a huge benefit for us.
But in addition, we found
quite a good way forward
to run these applications on
our standard cloud platforms
based on the template architecture.
So we only needed to use a
couple of specific topics,
so like Glue jobs and Step Functions
to take over some of
the batch functionality.
But like Fiserv, we also
made the use of opportunity
to optimize some of our
coding with reforge.
For us now, after
refactoring the applications,
that's really a good starting
point for further improvements
and functional enhancements
including embedding AI
in these kind of processes.
So what have been our results,
if you're looking at facts?
So we've been able to
significantly speed up
everything around testing.
So it saves us about
75% on the testing side
due to reduced time
for test case creation.
The test coverage could
be increased by up to 60%,
which is a significant number
and of course that leads in total also
to a shortened timeline
for all of your migrations.
On the other hand, we've
seen that we've been able
to improve the code quality
and that also leads to
better maintainability
of our refactored applications
from a 2.8 star rating
to a 4.1 rating, which is
a significant improvement.
So what do you learn from it
or what did we learn from it?
I think although AI did
a lot of heavy lifting,
a lot of groundwork, we
think it's still important
that you have a good plan
when you start doing your migrations.
So we think it's important
that you choose your
migration patterns wisely
and align that with your business owners
and your stakeholders.
If possible, I would recommend
go with technical conversion first
and then do functional enhancements.
And use the AI to first understand
where are your dependencies
and use it also to get a proper
documentation that helps you
to make informed decisions.
Taking over elements for us
from our production factories
with a high focus on continuous
improvement on standards
and efficiency has been
a key success factor
for our migration.
The team learned very fast
and improved the approach
and the tools with every single
step within the migration.
The close collaboration with
AWS helped us a lot to speed up
and we've seen that the agents
are developing very fast,
so there is even a huge potential
for further improvement.
So to sum it up, we are now able to solve
one of the biggest challenges in IT
to master mainframe migration
and that's really exciting
and I think what we should
not forget is at some stage
when we mastered all of the big migrations
that we also celebrate their success.
So thanks a lot and back to you, Meena.
(audience applauds)
- Thank you, Frank.
Well, I'm gonna close today
by connecting some of what
we heard from Frank and Vimal
with what patterns we're seeing
across multiple customers.
The first piece of it, yes,
we wanna embrace automation,
embrace intelligence where we can,
but using the right technology
for the right task is critical to success.
This is both the, you know,
this to me is true day to
day within AWS Transform
and each agent we're introducing,
each problem we're looking to solve.
But in your organizations,
as Frank just mentioned,
depending on what you're trying to achieve
with each phase of your
modernization journey,
it's important to select the right pattern
that maps to what that business,
what that team needs at
a given point in time.
The next piece of it is
testing is not something
that comes at the end as one big bang.
It's something that needs to
happen through the process.
Now at this re:Invent, we've
all heard the word agent
a couple times a day at least.
What to me, agentic AI
means in this context
really comes to light in
the context of reforge.
Last year, reforge was one
step took your refactored code,
improved it using your AI.
This year, reforge is
truly an agentic process
that not only does that
uplift of the refactored code,
but also tests that code to
confirm functional equivalences.
When it notices errors,
goes back and modifies
that initial uplifted code to test again
and continuously gets you to a point
where the human being
is three cycles ahead.
The ball goes as far down
the field as possible
before you need to bring a
human being into the process.
That to me is the acceleration
we're seeing with agentic AI.
Finally, we know that modernization
as much of a technology problem
and perhaps more so of a
people and process problem.
Bringing the team along
and ensuring that you are
bringing humans into the loop
and making the right decisions
with the combination of technical input
as well as this business context
is what sets teams up for success.
Through all of this, we are optimistic
and we're seeing early signs
that we can see over 70% reduction
in what that total time
looks like for teams.
And again, this is now
bringing the conversation
from multi-year scoping
down to the order of months
where you can see results
within a calendar year.
And what I'm hearing
from teams is actually
making the challenge or bringing
this up to the CIO's office
and bringing this to decision makers
a lot more tractable across the board.
And, like we say at AWS,
it is definitely day one.
Even in the modernization journey,
you'll see continuous improvements
as your teams are working on things
and agents are able to
bring in that learning loop
to improve along the way.
Similarly, what these agents
can do is also gonna continue
to improve month over
month, week over week
at the rate that technology
is advancing right now.
Finally, our goal is we're
still gonna need experts,
but we're gonna reduce the dependency
on the process as a
whole, on these experts.
So previously you might
have needed experts for 60%
of the journey to really
understand the code
and to elicit details from the code
and the legacy systems along the way.
Now AI can get them two
thirds of the way there,
so your same team of
experts can do a lot more
across projects than they've
been able to in the past.
So our goal here really is to
leverage the AI to accelerate
what these experts on
your teams can accomplish.
(audience applauds)
Thank you again for joining us today.
I wanna close with thanking, again,
thanking Vimal and Frank again
for telling their stories
and leave you with couple pointers
on how you can learn
more about AWS Transform.
If you feel that your teams
are ready for the mobilization
to start exploring modernization projects,
I recommend that you
get in touch with teams
to schedule an experience-based
acceleration process,
which is a one to two
day workshop that we do
where we work with your teams
to do an initial assessment,
pick an application,
and run through this
transform process with you.
Thanks again for your time and
for joining us at re:Invent.